foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
second program for 25th anniversary of
Atelier Series this year special
good evening everyone total game show
2022 this is official program of poet
Pokemon games I am shohei taguchi
today's MSC thank you
we have two parts in this program we are
going to introduce two games first part
the latest Game of Atria series
of the end and the secret key the first
guest
hello everyone
tgs2022 are you enjoying the TGs
please enjoy the r3a ryzer 3. hello
I am a voice actor of ryza Yuri noguchi
hello so you are very powerful with your
eyes I like that
next guest
hello I am in charge of character design
of The Secret Series thank you
and the other guest
hello everyone
um the cosplayer
thank you for coming so she is official
cosplayer of
out of the Ariza so she is wearing a
costume of Riser it is great it's so
cute
and I have a staff with me so the
quality is the 10 billion score so it's
perfect
how do you like it yes
so it is
so and this is a costume you are so cute
later we are going to have a screenshot
time so please stay tuned please have a
seat and we have other one
he is speaking from the above
thank you for having me so let's get
started so after the air Riser 3. hi
so please
talk about that and please show this
so actually I rise at three
celebrate 25th anniversary of Atria
series the second game it says the final
summer the final secret so Riser and
friends are going to start final summer
adventure and this is about the story
so the Story begins when there's a
mysterious island emerging in a water
surrounding kirken Island and it was
found out this island is doing harm to
kirken Island and the Riser does the
investigation and there's a gigantic
gate and riser start a great adventure
to look for the key and about the roots
of alchemy
this game is open field
so this is massive seamless map and you
can enjoy the adventure of riser
and next about characters
including Riser the main character there
are 11 party members which is one of the
largest in a series so ryzer has grown
and she is not just one of the girls
what do you mean
but she is not anyway
ordinary girls she is The Alchemist and
everyone trusts in her
in this game
and in story and the system that she is
very important you can use that in
battle field synthesis and the chi is
very important to enjoy the adventure
now we are going to show you
the promotion video of Atria ryzer 3
please watch
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
thank you
bye bye
now that is very uh exciting but uh it
gives you a lot of sentiment now we are
digging deep into design of Riser we
have three dominoes son who designed the
character and we have iori official
cosplayer and we are looking at the
design just like we did last time
yorisang is a official cosplayer of
riser
congratulations you are making the same
pose
yes it was actually hard to
make a move like this and strike a pose
like this it was very hard but it turned
out very good yes you are the only one
who know how hard it is to strike a pose
so the Riser is next to you how do you
feel
well I don't know where to look
but uh
you know the actual the character and
the actual costume that gives you the
different expression and we have the you
have the pins the I have the short ones
here
and you said that you don't know where
to look but he doesn't know where to
look right okay let's ask him then
so how do you feel the Riser is in front
of you so don't look at me
well you you created a character well I
would say she makes me happy
so what is great about this costume what
is the focus well the the one is more
simple and the local type costume the
two the second one is more like like a
city type so it is a combination so from
first second and third third one the the
shoulder part is getting lower
one it was like a high up here the
second the shoulder part was low lower
and the third one uh the shoulder part
is even lower so uh this is kind of the
uh The Continuous part of the costume so
it continues to get slower so I didn't
notice until you talk about it and there
is the belt nut side and the uh and the
Flesh on the thigh is on the Belt
so I thought that's how you design a
character
so I did not really design that way
so it is by Chance the costume is great
on you
and the staff here is great
as I was holding the stuff
so this stuff is beautiful just like
every time and this is actually heavy
you are wearing a costume do you have
any questions to foreign
in the first one
and a second one there was some angle
but third one the ribbon is straight
again why is that so the story goes back
to kirken Island so I wanted to have the
design similar to the first one so it is
shown in this ribbon angle
yes it is remarkable to see and hear the
story from the Creator
so it's great to discuss that but I also
I also want to really look at the
costume so why don't you strike a pose
in front of the camera
yes because the costume is beautiful I
want everyone to see the whole thing yes
your back is good yes
we cannot spend too much time so we have
40 seconds to strike a pose isn't it too
short the 40 seconds maximum why don't
we have a minute 40 seconds maximum I'm
sorry so you can take a screenshot or
you can just enjoy the costume so 40
seconds Starts Now
so please look at this
[Music]
so there's a big part here which is very
cute just like you see in the game
so and the staff here
yes
the the stuff is so real
the comment said they wants to see her
leg
that the camera should go lower
less than five seconds now
the time is limited time is limited
then time is finished
so I did not know 40 seconds is such a
short time
so that so I'm embarrassed
to strike a pose in front of camera
you know when I strike a pose for 30
seconds it is too long but uh this 40
seconds was very short
you have a right to make a request
okay or what about the uh one leg up
an active pose yes yes it is cute that's
what I wanted yeah
that's stuff and move the stuff maybe
and you hit the camera now
but the angle was great though
but you are not supposed to hit the
camera though
I'm sorry
that's that's my fault well it was very
uh active
no that was this fault not my fault
because we have no good son why don't
you say your lines and she is going to
make a pose okay I will I will say my
lines and why don't you shrike couples
everyone
join us for the final Adventure
thank you very much
[Music]
I'm so embarrassed now
because we have two of you we
can do this I think we did this
in the past yes and then we were all
embarrassed
but I think I'm less embarrassed I think
I'm getting used to it okay you are
growing now
thank you so much
how did you like it well the quality of
the costume play is very high well you
created it you didn't sound like it well
it was my honest feeling
so you're so how did you like it
how did you like it well your reason
husband we are in a costume from the uh
Riser one and she's doing that again and
I'm overwhelmed and it is remarkable
I'm making a heart with my fingers
now you are just one of the fans no she
makes me happy
well it was kind of the arbitrary
activities but now let's talk about the
game
so there are some information that is
out for the first time in pgs yes please
watch this
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
wow
what makes me smile
boss is a new member in this new title
wow
please write the three he's going to
join the venture
finally I would say
what do you think
it's razor too
much
wording
aren't you joining us so I've been
waiting for it
so there was some conversation with Riza
they knew each other for a long time so
I'm looking forward to watching the
scenes like that
it's like he's even cooler than before
maybe he did lots of practice
right
he has grown up
and there's a background
behind it
what is the key point
I personally
I think that rent is wild so I try to
make the costume
both made more formal what do you think
dress shirt
so I really like it when
a guy is wearing a shirt and rolling it
up the sleeves are rolled up
so you understand what we like
is shown
with a belt
I thought that was good
what do you think about this
he looks cooler
he looks like an elite
looks like he will be good at sports and
also good at studying
we really want to watch fighting scenes
he said he's finally part of the
adventure that was kind of a moving
scene
because who played one and two I thought
that was a very good information for you
both will join the adventure please look
forward to it and then if you are
interested in it
we are going to have a first program for
alteria series to commemorate 25th
anniversary we also show the key system
and tomorrow we have taken koi techno
live in TGs s 2022 and at 20 at 8
o'clock
and we will also show the actual play of
the game uh we have more information
okay here
is the information
will be available on February 22nd we
also have some gifts and
others for early purchasers
short sleeves please look forward to it
in addition to that
we also have uh saved the link a gift
also
we have a data linked date gift for
Atelier Sophie II and arteria series
we also have other gifts at each shops
for collection box and premium boxing
special box
and we also have a limited double pack
available for ataria raiser and arterial
Razer 2. please go to a shop to find it
foreign
please try and play it in addition to
that because of this TGs
at gas shop and Katie shop you can
purchase goods for more information
please visit the official site
there's more to it we have figures of
attires series at TGs we have a you
don't a life-sized laser but we have
other figures too please come and check
them next
this is manga rental app renter
we are going to have uh new episodes
and Sophie we are going to start
Distributing at 12 o'clock on Saturday
September 17th we were going to release
10 episodes first
we are going to have razor
we decided to collaborate with
Atelier Riser too but we are going to
have new characters from
Algeria riser 3.
lots of information thank you
please check the information
okay well we are coming to the end of
the first part I'd like to get a few
words before we close
no good son
of a sudden and we have this program
commemorating it
I'm looking forward to more information
to the launch
please stay tuned thank you thank you
very much
yes
we decided to Launch
of the Riser 3 which is next year and
I'm
happy to be involved in this
and I'm having fun
of course is going to join the adventure
with Raisa
I already played it at TGs
it was really fun
please look forward to it
well my Japanese doesn't sound great
today
thank you
[Music]
we will release more information as we
approach that
release please look forward to it
yes we'll get more information
thank you very much
please buy it
very simple but very compelling message
please take a look and check it
okay we are going to have a second part
which is about four long Fallen Dynasty
so we have to say goodbye to the guests
for the first section thank you very
much
[Music]
foreign
Germany
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
assistant
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
games start at 7 pm Japan time I am
shohei taguchi the MC for the second
part of the program as well second part
is all about warlong foreign Dynasty
we have guessed the producer of the game
good evening I am producer of Warren
from Team ninja
don't do that again okay
maybe people did not like it you know
there is a gap between the character and
your face and you didn't have to do that
I I just wanted to enjoy that
actually enjoyed it
so uh you know this is the dark game so
we have to make a dark program today
okay
next guest Mr yamagiva developer
development producer
so I am reluctant to speak now
after Mr yasuda well
I have to point out the teachers that
you are wearing what is it talk about it
so if you beat a certain stage in TGs
you get the T-shirt so when you are
defeated in a game now you see this word
on the screen so if you come to TGs you
see this word
what does it mean if they are all the
same from China when you are defeated
and your guts are all over the ground so
it is not peaceful expression
well actually you said guts well that is
not kind of the word you want to hear of
in program
this is a darker game so you have to say
that right
okay so let's talk about a world of war
room
foreign
yes we have the slide
so uh this game is new masoko
delivered by team ninja famous for Neo
so this is dark Three Kingdoms Massacre
so this is Chinese martial or art based
action game this is elegant and Speedy
and you can enjoy the tense battle
right and I wanted to give you here so
this is the original original story of
our nameless militia solution fighting
for survival in a dark fantasy version
of the Later Han Dynasty where demons
played the Three Kingdoms
and you will see the Warriors from Three
Kingdoms okay we are going to see the
Warriors from Three Kingdoms
so you this is a new strategy to go
against the difficulties so we have the
the system of morale so if you overcome
the difficulties you get stronger so uh
please stay tuned for more information
and this game
involves a lot of creators who uh claim
Us in Game movies drama pasama Coda does
the artwork action director Mr tanigaki
and music is composed by Mr yusuhiro
okay you made announcement in June and
you have received a lot of reaction
around the world right
so do you feel the reaction yes we do
so this is the different game from Neo
as a team ninja this is the first game
of China
and so I think this is the unique game
that you can enjoy so this is the game
of China you will enjoy it okay so this
is the uh China based game and this is
masoko again so I want to play
so you talked about the game
so I think we should post a gameplay so
let's watch the gameplay and listen to
the story
yesterday
please start
so we have a
stage as a trial version
very nice
very nice Graphics right
we try to show the nice landscape of
China
the beginning of the will again
we heard Roma
yellow turban Rebellion that's a very
uh
famous event
I'm sure fans are already familiar with
Three Kingdoms so I we try to meet their
expectations
I want to also ask you about the actions
I think many are watching this for the
first time
there they use different weapons in
martial arts
depends how they
fight against you you can change the way
you fight
and so and you can
make them weaker
many weapons yes
China
there's some weapons unique to this era
or we have some traditional weapons
depends on the preference of the player
you can think about your own strategy
what's this flag
this is the flag for the Army
and you can raise your level
and if you put the flag that means it
control the area and you can also grow
with it so you are expanding your
territory correct
by putting a flag out now I'm world
three
[Music]
oh the tiger you see five
this shows the
parameter for strength
but you see the opponent is five so
the opponent is stronger correct
the sword is burning yes this is also
one of the technique
foreign
we have actions with fire this action is
good for fire
right bottom
yes
this is kind of a magic
or tactics
and utilizing it you can be stronger in
a better position in fighting
I was watching it
so we you are spreading out all the guts
the movement is
compared to the previous enemy
yes
we try to make sure that it's quick
and if you defeat the enemy
you can get some equipment and yes
but then you can get stronger
can you explain this briefly
five
types
how you can get stronger
and each one is unique
we focus on the right top now but uh you
want to be more offensive or more
supportive or you can maintain good
balance among five
or you can focus on one area
or if you want to enhance one strength
that's okay too you just defeat enemies
yes you can get values as experience
everybody
depends on the player's preference you
can allocate the points to the strength
when you are defeated you lose this
experience value
forever
you also have to decide whether you're
going to go and fight to her
run away from it
is that a person
told you
he is one of the Warrior from the yellow
turban Rebellion
you got it and you lost HP
the Green Gauge is HP and the gauge
below that is for Spirit
so if the enemy is stronger you see
orange
and if the gauge goes all the way then
you won't be able to do anything anymore
but then you can go back please deflect
and when you use tactics at the the
value on the gauge goes down what is
this
changes
Divine Beast
we by using it you are in a better
position now
the timing of deflect is quite
sensitive
yes the move mental Force you have to
understand it
better
yeah already mustard how to do it
so his play is quite smooth
but uh if you are beginner it's
difficult but if you get used to playing
with it
so when the deflect success succeeds and
then it
the enemies in the town studies
very nice actions
I'm surprised myself
I'm playing well today
the boss is different for the trial
version
so I wanted to show a different version
of Boss
then you you're getting defeated
as you speak to us
it's more interesting now
oh please defeat it defeat boss
can you
get in close
that was a nice move
defeated
defeated
they got all over the place
we have more time
probably not I wanted you to win
but that was a very stylish play
and you are going to show something new
first in TGs right yes we are going to
introduce the stage with lubu I think
you know him when you know Three
Kingdoms so we are we are going to see
lubu
Le yes it is available available for
online multiplayer so there are some
moves you can make
yes so it's kind of
Chinese moves and you can use these
moves to make a communication like Bruce
Lee I feel Kung Fu here
so let's start the battle
well it is great and dark
so Lulu is on red hair yes
you know the Lulu is the best human
being the red hair is the best horse you
know he is the most powerful in the
Three Kingdoms
and the life is less than half
you are supposed to be doing good today
right
but uh
so it's not really win or lose I I want
to do the deflect
when I
reflect the attack
we can take Lulu down from Red pair but
now I'm defeated
by touching again
he can still fight he can still fight we
have we have some time
so so it means that I get defeated
twice three times or four times
well I want to see that lubu's life gets
halved
which one do you want to see like a test
clay version
or the other version
maybe I can take a Revenge so let's do
the battle against Google again
well I didn't say I'm going to defeat
him
so there are
a number of uh crushing defeats the
players experienced in kgs now I want
you to show us uh we can win
or lubu is the most powerful person on
the planet
well one attack is so powerful
yes
that lubu is the boss you will see in
the middle or toward the end of the game
so he's very strong
foreign
when you play and you cannot defeat the
boss you want to earn a lot of
experience points yes you can do that or
you can do the multiplayer we see
another if fighter J I was going to talk
a lot I I wanted to talk more
I use the one item to recover my life
but it didn't work
so uh you know you uh that again even
sooner you know uh
has been a great weapon and he is good
at um ball and arrow and he is with the
red hair and he's too strong
maybe we have a time for another battle
yes one last battle
do you want to do it no no I don't want
to do it
why start
we are not totally torturing you so why
don't you play
I was not expecting to play against lubu
well the longer you saw the game and the
uh the better the users understand about
the game so you are doing a PR activity
right now
yes she is really agile
and I want you to take him down from red
hair first
and I am reducing his spirit
and it's easy to say it but uh it's very
difficult to do it now he is on the
ground
[Music]
nice maybe not no chance
again crash in defeat actually uh four
defeats the record high during the live
streaming I'm embarrassed
so it's great game to play right yes the
players try and I want all the players
to beat blue yes please do the revenge
for us
thank you it was a lot of information
the first information in TCS and we know
more about the game and please look
forward to more new information
and that was the gameplay for a warlong
foreign
we heard many stories we are coming to
an end of the session
so I'd like to ask more information from
yesterday this is a information we are
showing for the first time
we decided to distribute this trial
version
eight o'clock today
simultaneously on the globe
right after this program yes I didn't
want to say it till now
we are also doing the Twitter camping at
the same time this is again starts at
eight o'clock Japan time and this is
going to be held on Twitter
please
tweet a 30 second uh play video with a
hashtag and you
um
I'm going to get this t-shirt that we
are wearing
yes I want this t-shirt defeated t-shirt
yes I hope this becomes popular yes
thank you
[Music]
it's fun when I see my face
and we are going to give you as much as
75 percent discount
a steam and peace store sales 75 is a
lot yes okay
we had lots of information for you
finally I would like to get a message
from you to your fans
we are going to distribute the trial
version I hope that many people will
enjoy it and please give us your friend
feedback based on your feedback
we want to reflect it in the title thank
you thank you very much
Was Defeated four times during the
program
I really like three kingdom when I was
in the elementary school this was my
dream to make this title
we there are many titles regarding Three
Kingdoms but this is the first one from
three team Ninja
and we make sure that the title will be
a good one for you thank you very much
for your time
a Twitter campaign earlier what kind of
uh videos you're looking for
you're very close
but then finally you were defeated
when you were deflecting
was trying to tailor his tactics against
the enemy but uh we want to watch super
play you can do it too
yes we want to
see your super play but after that we
want lots of defeats
yes correct
I really like the word defeated
looking forward to getting lots of
videos
this is it for the program
thank you very much for staying with us
till the end thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]